[Musik]
geschlossene leben blockierte kassen ein
hacker angriff auf ein us unternehmen
hat weltweit auswirkungen langfristiger
denken im zdf-sommerinterview ermahnt
bundespräsident steinmeier die parteien
und waren vor einer schlammschlacht im
wahlkampf mit der hitze kommt das feuer
im westen kanadas kämpfen feuerwehrleute
gegen mehr als 170 waldbrände
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem sonntag
an meiner seite ist für den sport
norbert könig guten abend
sie blockieren computersysteme legen
damit firmen lahm und verlangen lösegeld
wieder haben hacker zugeschlagen in den
usa betroffen sind hunderte von
unternehmen auch deutsche
die hacker nutzten offenbar eine
schwachstelle bei einem großen
amerikanischen it dienstleister kaseya
kunden auf der ganzen welt sind
betroffen
seit jahren steigt die zahl der
cyberangriffe 2020 waren es allein in
deutschland rund 108.000 der schaden pro
jahr liegt über 100 milliarden euro über
den aktuellen angriff berichtet thomas
concia nein kein einkauf hier kunden
kommen nicht rein
denn es sind hacker reingekommen tief
ins kassensystem des supermarktriesen co
ob die folge hunderte filialen in
schweden geschlossen und die dimension
ist noch grösser unternehmen in 17
ländern sollen betroffen sein
auch deutsche alle nutzen software des
us-anbieters kassel
der verdacht es waren russische hacker
us präsident biden hat die geheimdienste
eingeschaltet
wenn die russische regierung davon
wusste oder dahinter steckt dann so habe
ich präsident putin gesagt werden wir
reagieren was gewiss ist ist das prinzip
über die kaseya software hätten sich
kriminelle in unternehmen ein
sie verschlüsselt und wichtige daten und
geben sie nur gegen lösegeld wieder
heraus in deutschland gelangten sie nun
ins system eines it-dienstleisters also
wohl in zahlreiche firmen und tausende
computer solche attacken mehren sich
warnt der bundesverband der deutschen
industrie
noch nie wurde die deutsche wirtschaft
so stark angegriffen
die anzahl der angriffe ist in der
korona pandemie weiter gestiegen um
mindestens fünf prozent so versicherer
opfer waren zuletzt tegut märkte
einfallstor für schadsoftware vor allem
das home-office corona eine pandemie
auch von computerviren vor allem sind
die privaten rechnern problem auf die
dann zwar schutz software aufgespielt
wird die aber häufig dann doch nicht so
wirkungsvoll ist deutschland im
cybercrime zeitalter erst ab morgen an
den werktagen zeigt sich wohl das ausmaß
der aktuellen attacke schauen wir auf
die aktuellen corona zahlen die sind
leicht nach oben gegangen das robert
koch institut meldet 559 neuinfektionen
binnen 24 stunden das sind 21 mehr als
vergangenen sonntag
außerdem kamen sieben todesfälle dazu
erstmals seit wochen ist auch die sieben
tage incidence wieder leicht gestiegen
um 0,1 auf 5 wer seinen impftermin
verfallen lässt ohne vorher abzusagen
soll eine geldstrafe zahlen das fordert
neben anderen spd gesundheitsexperte
lauterbach in der bild am sonntag weist
er darauf hin dass impfstoff
weggeschmissen werden müsse wenn termine
ausfallen
cdu-chef lasche ist gegen bußgelder
solidarität könne man nicht erzwingen
wir werden uns verändern müssen das sagt
bundespräsident steinmeier mit blick auf
die herausforderungen der zukunft die
parteien mahnt er auch nach den
angriffen auf die grünen
kanzlerkandidaten baerbock vor einer
schlammschlacht im bundestagswahl
außerdem äußerte er sich im zdf
sommerinterview
zu seinen eigenen chancen auf eine
wiederwahl christian hübsche treffen mit
dem bundespräsidenten auf dem gipfel des
brocken im harz ein sommerinterview auf
1141 metern höhe in dem es auch um ihnen
persönlich gehen muss denn frank walter
steinmeier der sich kürzlich selbst für
eine zweite amtszeit vorgeschlagen hat
weiß dass er aktuell keine mehrheiten
hinter sich hat seine wiederwahl alles
andere als sicher ist wird sicherlich im
verlaufe dieses halbjahres auch noch
thematisiert werden müsste es nicht eine
frau sein
und da kann ich auch nur sagen ich kann
nur als der kandidierende ich bin bringe
das mit was man von mir kennt und das
wird entweder wertgeschätzt oder nicht
wertgeschätzt
wie kommt deutschland durch die krise
fragt theo koll den bundespräsidenten
nicht als weltmeister aber auch nicht
als klassen letzter antwortet der nicht
genügend vorbereitet aber sieht
steinmeier das land für die
bevorstehenden herausforderungen
das geht an keinem bereich der
gesellschaft vorbei wohnen bauen
mobilität autofahren schule
landwirtschaftlichen zukunft des
ländlichen raumes alles das
unterschätzen wir glaube ich in der
dynamik der veränderung die vor uns
liegt da ist viel mut erforderlich für
diejenigen die nach dem september
regierungsverantwortung gewinnen
ein bundespräsident im t shirt geht nach
dem sommerinterview auf wandertour mit
naturschützern und bürgermeistern aus
dem harz schritt für schritt so heißt
steinmeiers begegnungsprogramm gemeinsam
raus aus der pandemie hans-georg maßen
cdu hat dem öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk meinungsmanipulation
vorgeworfen und damit empörung ausgelöst
auch in der eigenen partei seine
forderung nach charakterlicher prüfung
von journalisten sei inakzeptabel sagte
der niedersächsische cdu chef althusmann
und legte maßen dem parteiaustritt nahe
maaßen hatte in einem interview
redakteuren der tagesschau verbindungen
zur linken und linksextremen szene
unterstellt
nach der gewaltigen schlammlawine die
gestern teile der japanischen
küstenstadt atami verschüttet hat suchen
rettungskräfte weiter nach opfern
zwei menschen konnten sie nur noch tot
bergen etwa 20 werden noch vermisst
wegen anhaltender regenfälle warnen
experten vor weiteren erdrutschen
auch in den usa und kanada kämpfen die
menschen seit tagen gegen eine
naturkatastrophe im westen kanadas gibt
es mittlerweile mehr als 170 waldbrände
besonders betroffen ist die provinz
british columbia
dort wurde die armee mobilisiert um die
feuerwehr zu unterstützen
auch in den usa wüten waldbrände in
mehreren bundesstaaten an der westküste
wegen extremer hitze und trockenheit
breiten sich die flammen schnell auswahl
bot es ist ein sommer der katastrophen
an der westküste kanadas und der usa
erst die jahrhunderthitze jetzt hunderte
hektar land in flammen
besonders hart traf es die menschen im
kleinen ort litten 250 kilometer
nördlich von vancouver
hier erreichte die rekordhitze letzte
woche fast 50 grad dann raste das feuer
auf den ort zu den 250 bewohnern blieben
nur minuten um sich in sicherheit zu
bringen
es kommt auf uns zu nichts wie raus hier
sagt die frau im handy video
ich konnte nur noch meinen hund
schnappen nicht mal die tür abschließen
und jetzt sehe ich drüben unser haus
schon in flammen so die geschockte frau
zwei menschen starben auch weiter
südlich an der westküste der usa breiten
sich die feuer aus wie hier im ort liegt
nördlich von san francisco
schon im letzten sommer hatten riesige
waldbrände fast vier prozent der
gesamtfläche kaliforniens zerstört und
mehr als 30 menschenleben gefordert
dieses jahr kommt noch die extreme hitze
bei anhaltenden hochdruckwetter dazu ein
phänomen deswegen klimawandels jetzt
häufiger auftritt
die behörden der westlichen
bundesstaaten haben wegen der hohen
brandgefahr die nutzung von
feuerwerkskörpern zum amerikanischen
nationalfeiertag heute strikt untersagt
zur fußball wm das halbfinale ist
komplett und die engländer brauchen
jetzt noch zwei heimsiege zum lang
ersehnten titel ja genau
dank wenig reisestress könnte das
eventuell auch klappen
nach dem berauschenden 4 zu 0 gegen die
ukraine in rom geht es zurück nach
wembley am mittwoch warten dort
entfesselte denen ganz in weiß haben die
das rot weiße fußball märchen weiter
geschrieben
mit dem 2 2 1 erfolg gegen tschechien
danish dynamite das dänische dynamit ist
im ganzen lande explodiert die beiden
tore durch den dortmunder thomas delaney
und durch kaspar dolberg zum 2 1 erfolg
gegen tschechien haben dafür gesorgt
dass viele kleine kinder in dänemark
jetzt wieder nationalspieler werden
wollen die ganze dänische leute sind so
so von stolz und das ist ein super
moment moment
ähnliche bilder auch in england nach dem
4 0 spaziergang gegen die ukraine vor
allem kapitän harry caine machte mit
zwei toren da weiter wo er zuvor gegen
das deutsche team aufgehört hatte so wie
hier zu gewinnen ein großer tag für
englischen fußball
jetzt fehlen nur noch zwei weitere große
tage zum ersten englischen
fünfter saisonsieg dritter nacheinander
der niederländer max verstappen gewinnt
wie vor wochenfrist an selber stelle den
formel 1 grand prix in spielberg
österreich max verstappen führt nach dem
start vor länder norris im
orangefarbenen mclaren die mercedes
piloten wieder keine gegner für den
niederländer lewis hamilton r kämpft
sich zunächst rang zwei dann baut der
linke hinterreifen massiv ab sowohl
fotos als auch der mclaren-pilot
überholen ihn bekommen aber keinen
kontakt zur spitze sebastian vettels
wochenende bedeutungslos nach strafe und
startplatz elf räumt kimi räikkönens
alfa romeo den deutschen von der strecke
er wird nur 17 verstappen siegt vor
bottas und norris seien erneute erfolg
beschert ihm jetzt schon 30 punkte
vorsprung in der wm vor lewis hamilton
die hauptstadt der niederlande
dankeschön norbert im nördlichen bayern
warnt der deutsche wetterdienst vor
schweren gewittern mit starkregen
morgen ist es im norden und der mitte
oft bewirkt und einige teils kräftige
schauer und gewitter im süden länger
freundlich und weitgehend trocken
höchstwerte 20 bis 26 grad und es bleibt
unbeständig am dienstag im osten bis zu
32 grad im westen kühle und neue
kräftige gewitter viertel vor zehn ist
die zeit für das heute journal mit
marietta slomka wir sagen danke tschüss
und bis morgen hier kommt jetzt das zdf
sommerinterview der bundespräsident im
gespräch mit theo koll